how's it going reject nation greg and
john here today after seeing on social
media stupid cosmic warren being
promoted in the shanghai trailer lucky
son of a bee i was there when kevin
feige said if you call this a
masterpiece i'll pay you a thousand
dollars you shill now that's his honest
opinion dang it i can't blame him for
anything guys i want to say thank you
really quick for uh helping us get to we
kind of number seven on trending i
believe that is all due to koi john drew
yeah he uh absolutely killed in that
video i mainly wanted him to come on so
he had another chance to shine here on
the internet and thank you to everyone
who followed him we got over a thousand
followers on youtube a bunch of social
media followers as well so thank you you
guys rock i really wanted him to have
the love and support and he got it he
deserves it he'll be on more so we're
gonna watch today spider-man no way home
and he's in a lot on social media
because of cinemacon in a couple days
avengers 5 deadpool 3 black panther 2
and trailer updates let's see what's
going on
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
yesterday a lot of news released the
press junket for shanghi and the legend
of the tin ring started which means
interviews are happening and a lot of
people have been interviewing marvel
studios as president kevin feige and
they've actually surprisingly been
getting a lot of information from him
some of it big some of it not so big but
regardless there is a lot to go over
today including of course spider-man
nelly home avengers 5 the next avengers
movie deadpool 3 big black next avengers
mcu be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos so
first things first i know everybody
wants to know about spider-man no way
home and some of you may have heard this
but kevin feige did indeed confirm we
will be getting a trailer before the
movie comes out now of course this isn't
breaking news but some people were
actually no way believe that perhaps
they weren't actually going to release a
trailer the marketing strategy for
spider-man no way home has been a little
bit different than we've seen for pretty
much anything in the past but i do
believe that this is due to the fact
that it's going to be an insanely huge
film and right now they're not exactly
sure if they're going to keep that
release date as of right now it's the
same and hopefully it stays that way but
i did actually happen to hear some news
recently about footage at cinemacon on
monday according to a personal source of
mine sony does indeed have something
prepared for spiderman home for
cinemacon it was not classified whether
or not this is a trailer or footage he
simply said something is prepared now
will the public see that right away
probably not we're probably not going to
see that monday maybe tuesday but that
is not confirmed it's just a guess at
this point in time you have no idea how
stressed out i am about this i've
already snapped out okay we gotta be
around here in the evening for sure yeah
we'll wait probably away from like six
to nine pm our time then i gotta wake up
at like five in the morning the next day
to get ready just in case it comes out
at 6 00 a.m when sony usually drops your
trailer and if it doesn't come out then
it's like great just an infinite holding
pattern of it could be any minute now i
just know that once we go back to sleep
like all right screw it fine let's just
call it it's gonna drop i know what's
gonna happen it's gonna happen again
it's gonna happen two marvel trailers in
a row and i also love how this kevin
feige thing is becoming news
it will be a trailer guys
before there's no point
it's so stupid gotta give credit to
whoever asked that question people are
going to come out of that cinemacon
footage trailer whatever they're showing
and they're going to talk and the second
i hear anything about it i'll be sure to
do a video on it asap we're going to
react to that
some of the official sony youtube
channels have made a playlist now for
spiderman no way home and the current
thing and the only thing that's in the
playlist is the title reveal but the
playlist is made which means other
videos for no way home are coming gotta
be added away from getting a description
now we do have some avengers 5 news from
kevin feige himself in an interview that
he did with collider the mcu is a lot
bigger than it was back in 2012 and the
notion that you can now bring everybody
together will take a lot more than four
years so after stating this collider
steven weintraub asked marvel studios
president about when the next team-up
film avengers 5 could be in which kevin
feige said this i think we want there to
be a reasonable amount of time from the
end game to start a new saga which is
already underway and already started and
then you need time as you did in phase
one to build that saga before you start
bringing everyone together now clearly
things are different now i love the way
that stated only five movies released
before avengers came out and right now
we technically only have one movie that
has been released that will actually go
into avengers 5 because unfortunately
black widow won't so right now we just
have shang chi of course the disney plus
shows will tie into the avengers but not
everybody is going to be a part of the
new avengers team so although kevin
feige does say that it's underway and
groundwork is being laid it'll probably
be another four to five years until we
get a new avengers team at the most at
least perhaps we could get it a little
bit before but we'll probably need
another four to five movies about people
who are actually going to be a part of
the new avengers team because not
everybody is but it is actually good
that marvel is taking their time with
this we don't want things to get
repetitive yeah i love the way kevin
feige stated that weirdly the the thing
that hasn't been on my mind is the next
avengers movie yeah absolutely you know
i've been excited for these new slated
characters and it feels like when you go
back to the time of phase one after the
iron man was a log the iron man one post
credits scene with nick fury it's been
like onesie avengers coming when's the
avengers coming and it kept feeling like
a lead up to the team up here it's been
exciting to kind of just get the new
movies and the new characters and the
new shows so that way by the time you
get the actual next declared avengers
titled movie it's gonna feel that much
more special and that much more exciting
i love the way he was saying that
because i'm like oh yeah i've really
been thinking about i've heard about
young avengers from about a new event
i've had dark adventures but i haven't
really been thinking about avengers 5.
yeah absolutely i mean this is the
mentality that's led them to where they
are now they understand the value in
letting us miss the team and building
anticipation for that and to give the
spotlight to their new characters enough
that we care when they team yeah and in
all fairness you know a lot of more of
these solo movies are going to still be
having more crossovers and what's cool
about it now is that avengers still
feels alive
throughout all these films you know and
still reference and stuff so it's not
like we're just waiting around to see
the team up because you still feel like
it's percolating all around us yeah and
we'll get deadpool 3 before we get
avengers 5 which to me is great news
because i really hope deadpool is a part
of the next avengers team i think it
would be
in an interview with kevin feige brandon
davis asked him if they have a release
date window set for deadpool 3 to make
his mcu debut and kevin feige said this
we do and the script is in the works and
ryan is working very hard on it with our
writers as we speak so this is extremely
good news and i actually kind of heard
something at the premiere of chongqi
nothing major but i did pretty much hear
that ryan reynolds right now is pretty
much just devoting all of his time to
writing the script he's pretty much just
taking his kids to school writing the
script picking them up writing the
script some more and this is great
because recently he stated that there's
about a 70 chance that they're going to
start filming in 2022 which means we'll
probably get the movie late 2022 or
early 2023 which means it's not that far
away which is awesome because i know
everybody is super excited for ryan
reynolds and deadpool to enter the
marvel cinematic universe man the
journey of deadpool has been one hell of
an adventure how long we
wanted just that first deadpool movie
and then like the decade it took to get
to just get that first movie and then
how special deadpool has become now
after the fox disney merger the the
weight in anticipation now not just for
deadpool 3 but what deadpool is gonna be
in the marvel cinematic universe yeah
i'm not sure if you were there in that
were you there in that moment
you never know who you might talk to
that might
yep okay
i don't know what you're talking about
keep this a little more private now we
have some pretty big iron heart and
black panther to wakanda forever news
coming from the same interview with
kevin foggy and comicbook.com kevin
feige told comicbook.com we're shooting
black panther wakanda forever right now
and the character of riri williams you
will meet in black panther 2 first
marvel studios has announced that
dominique thorne is going to be playing
the character of riri williams and kevin
feige said that she started shooting i
think this week before her iron heart
series so riri williams iron heart is
going to be in black panther 2 which
makes me think that perhaps her iron man
suit could be made by radium i knew you
were going to say
the video i've ever done is about a
theory that iron man was going to get a
vibranium suit for infinity war and
ingame
how cool would that be
how cool
did confirm that loki season 2 is
underway he stated it is underway we're
developing it as we speak the hope is
that much of the same team will return
kate is going on to bigger and better
things so the director search will begin
shortly michael bay that's the one or
simon west accurate so far yesterday we
did receive the final eternals trailer
and like i said i did hear from a source
that they are going to be showing
spider-man no way home footage at
cinemacon on monday which leads me to
believe that the other rumors i've been
hearing are probably somewhat true as
well meaning that we should be getting a
hawkeye trailer this month or next month
perhaps at the emmys a miss marvel
trailer perhaps at the same time and a
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness trailer before the end of the
year however i'm not so sure about that
doctor strange one but never mind the
news that happened yesterday like i said
it was a lot but things are starting to
get really really exciting in the mcu so
let me know all of your thoughts about
this in the comments down below and how
excited you are don't forget to give the
video a like if you enjoyed it and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
all right
well thank you warren for that video i
will send you a text message criticizing
everything with my notes
and how you can improve your channel
because you need the help
absolutely all right guys
well follow my man warren on his channel
as soon as you can congrats ward on
being recognized by marvel subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button last but not least
jean jeter listen man you've been so
magical in our lives i'm gonna start
calling you genie jeter
that's right or gene the genie jeter how
does that sound you've been granting
wishes left and right for us that wish
being never leave our patreon page from
day one from when you pledge and you
have maintained that consistency brother
if i had three wishes my first wish
would be one
maintain your pledge
two double your pledge
three triple your pledge without asking
for anything in return including no
shout out but i will stick with number
one wish right now because you are brand
new to this genie business it takes a
few years to really master the wish
granting business this is a real john
shout out today you're killing it with
photography yeah you're doing so great
with your wacky weird videos
look to greg look over to
am i doing okay absolutely all right
wondering everything yeah move my chair
a little uncomfortable
but also trying to be relaxed it's a
paradox
see ya
you